hi there you know the last little while
I haven't been doing much Persian I
didn't listen to Persian I stopped doing
my tutor sections with my Persian tutor
I kind of lost interest and that kind of
continued that way and then I said you
know what I should get back to it and
the interesting thing here is once I
started listening to some Persian again
all the history of Iran I got Keen again
and then I said now I'll set up a
session with my tutor the message here
is you know sometimes you just have to
take that first step
just get going and once you get going
you realize that you actually enjoyed
doing that it's when you're away from it
you convince yourself you don't want to
do it you get going again and once again
you like doing it so take that first
step get back into your language
learning okay that's all for now bye